hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the hundredth floor
horror house experience elevator thingy
I think it's like a haunted house where
each floor you go up there's another
[ __ ] experience it's gonna scare the
piss out of you but then again I don't
know somehow wired up and confused and
ready to go and all good I smudged my
oculus rift well that's fantastic when
it's up on my head there's like oh oh
press space so I thought it was I
thought it was okay anyway so the
Creator is not liable for any damage
that may be caused by the use of this
demo I actually don't think I'm moving
at all so I think it's just me and my
wits against Oh yep that is an elevator
as far as I can tell having seen many
elevators in my time and hello there
shrieking shootin so you should see
something sure do detail cause I didn't
see one intentionally but I should also
do this in the Samsun see I should also
mention that sure okay I should mention
that the developer is also Chinese so I
don't think that we'll be able to
understand it
but I think that the basic concept will
be the same and I'm hoping that the
gameplay itself will not be altered by
that understanding of Chinese which I'm
assuming that it won't because I don't
see how I could in the first place but
either way I'm ready bring it on come on
I hear ya I'm ready for you bring it on
you bastard I got my weapons all prepped
we're nothing at all oh hi
ah that's nuts oh hi okay okay could you
back up a tad could you back up like ten
Tad's thank you very much well that was
that this is an object coming at me that
wasn't scary come on bring on the fear
I'm ready for you by the way this is
just a demo there's only ten floors
available come on what's the app for me
oh how you doing
well I mean you sit oh oh oh oh oh oh
did I did I do that to the okay I'm
confused now
oh hi that's delightful that's very nice
hello phone could you shut up I'm in the
middle of something what is Godzilla
gonna come and attack what are those
things in the sky oh that's a crane okay
so so what about this oh no no you don't
oh no you okay alright okay
ya ain't gonna get me yeah son of a
[ __ ] oh god this is weird I'm flying
through the air
I am litter okay alright okay god this
is weird with the oculus rift I got like
my hands out cos trying to stop myself
but it's like I don't want to go out
don't make me go out okay I get it okay
good god you son of a [ __ ]
God Jesus the way the oculus rift f2
actually gives you depth of field it's
very disconcerting even if this doesn't
look realistic some object coming at
your face at a million miles an hour
doesn't feel too good
I wonder what city that is you know I
don't write oh I'm not gonna fall out
are you gonna drop I'm gonna drop agent
okay alright can we no no no no no no no
no no okay
[Music]
but if I didn't think that it was
screwing I still have my hands I'm gonna
put these down now well put away my
weapons here I said ah if this wasn't
trying to kill me
I would assume that this is kind of fun
oh good lordy okay all right cool cool
no it's fun let's go to another floor
now oh my god oh hi can we go another
floor please
this one's making me sick I'm gonna
throw up if you keep doing this I am
going to vom and you're not gonna let
out some mirrored it's totally mirrored
that is a pretty picture that is a very
pretty picture it's also mirrored the
other way that's why it's doing the
thing okay God what does it want from me
what are you one for became developer is
that supposed to be Beijing or Hong Kong
I don't know okay no no okay you stop
that [ __ ] right now okay here we go
oh we're going on a ride I keep doing
this I keep doing this
okay okay okay oh you dick you dick you
son of a [ __ ] oh my god
icky eyes literally cannot stop doing
this okay I'm gonna put these down oh hi
that was like five floors oh oh my god
this is ridiculous
this is insanity this is madness no okay
that is blood all right then
or it's oh hi how about you don't that
is so cheesy and yet so disturbing
okay those it was like it was like not
like not ten floors yeah okay all right
okay all right okay all right oh I'm
sweating seriously I don't know if it
was conveyed properly when you guys saw
it but when the thing was moving around
and because there's depth of field in
here it was literally like I don't wanna
don't make me do it I really don't wanna
but that was really really cool besides
the point that was really cool I would
love to see a hundred floors of that but
I don't think I could do it all in one
sitting because flying through the city
kind of made me feel it anyway if you
have an oculus rift and you want to play
this check the link in the description
if you want to see more horror games
well this wasn't exactly that much
horror but it was kind of who's more
cool than anything but if you want to
see more of this link in the description
to an entire playlist click the
annotation if you enjoyed this video
please leave a like down below and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
welcome